un dialogue raisonnable et nécessaire
pour stargate lavrorv une discussion
honnête et substantielle pour anthony
blinken et chef de la diplomatie russe
et américaine ont accordé chacun de leur
côté une conférence de presse à l'issue
de leur entretien entretien consacré à
la situation en ukraine et sous fond de
tensions avec la russie
pour en savoir plus on retrouve david
khalifa notre envoyée spéciale à genève
david bonjour que peut-on retenir de cet
entretien de sergueï lavrov avec son
homologue américain
[Musique]
pas d'avancée massive dans les
négociations ici à genève elle n'a des
gens comme on pouvait s'y attendre après
plus d'une heure trente d'entretiens
mais une discussion franche et honnête
comme vous avez pu le dire à la voie
diplomatique est évidemment la meilleure
façon de régler cette crise pour anthony
blinken et sergueï lavrov les deux sont
venus se présenter à la presse après
leur entretien le chef de la diplomatie
russe a été avec les airs il attend de
la partie américaine des réponses
écrites aux propositions de moscou et
dès la semaine prochaine notamment sur
l'élargissement de l'otan et des
retraits des troupes étrangères de
roumanie et bulgarie la question
ukrainienne a largement été abordé
également saga et lavrov a de nouveau
souligné la nécessité d'une désescalade
et il a réaffirmé que la russie avait
aucunement l'intention d'envahir
l'ukraine écouter la russie n'a jamais
est
en tout cas par ses responsables
officiels n'a jamais proféré de menaces
contre le peuple ukrainien et le
président lnsq et et qui est soutenue
encouragée
par les pays occidentaux il a dit
clairement que ceux qui
se sent russe en ukraine qu il dégage
aille en russie et ceux qui se donnent
basse et qui s'opposent
au terrorisme d'état delà
de la part du régime de kiev il a traité
ce genre
d'individu
et nous n'excluons pas que toute cette
hystérie qui
se déchaînent qui est déchaînée par nos
collègues européens occidentaux nous
n'excluons pas qu'elles soient orientés
non pas pour provoquer
des actes armée de la part de le thème
en tout cas pour couvrir la
le sabotage complet désaccord de minsk
des mots qui n'ont pas suffi à apaiser
anthony et habib kane qui réclame et des
garanties et s'appuie sur ce qui est
visible en faisant référence aux troupes
russes à la frontière ukrainienne
anthony à busnes qu'elle souhaite
rappeler dans ces mots que la russie a
envahi d'ukraine en 2014 il affirme
également que moscou établi une certaine
pression pour à déstabiliser et
renverser le gouvernement ukrainien
le fait est que la russie a rassemblé
des forces très importante à la
frontière ukrainienne et continue de le
faire cent mille soldats y compris
l'effort se déployer en biélorussie cela
donnerait à la russie la capacité si le
président poutine ne décide d'attaquer
l'ukraine par le sud l'est ou le nord et
nous avons vu des plans pour
entreprendre une variété d'actions de
déstabilisation
certaines parlent usage excessif de la
force pour déstabiliser l'ukraine pour
renverser son gouvernement
roche
pour rappel washington accordé une aide
de 200 millions de dollars des deux
sécuritaire défensif supplémentaire à
kiev attitude jugée provocatrice par le
kremlin vous l'aurez compris genève elle
devait être le théâtre de l'apaisement
d'une atmosphère de guerre froide -
pesant et bien on est loin de ce
résultat de nouveaux pourparlers vont
prochainement avoir lieu elle mais pour
l'instant la l1 passé est toujours un
bel et bien elle présente chaque camp ne
voulant céder aucune concession
david qualifer en direct de genève merci
pour cette précision